willkommen zur aktuellen sitzung heute
geht es noch einmal um das thema
künstliche intelligenz und robotik genau
genommen geht es um robotik wir hatten
uns damit schon mal befasst als wir
dieses buch machine ethik diskutiert
habe ich nach oben rechts und links zu
dieser sitzung rein heute geht es noch
mal ganz konkret um den einsatz
besonderer roboter nämlich von
sogenannten kampfrobotern autonomen
kriegs oder kampfrobotern das ist ja
eine neuentwicklung wir sehen das leider
auch immer mehr jetzt bei den kriegen
die herrschen da sehen wir auch dass da
drohnen zu gange sind die man auch so
halbautonomen nennen kann die sind
natürlich nicht ganz autonom die müssen
gesteuert werden überhaupt stellt sich
die frage ob
diese geräte wirklich autonom sind wir
hatten in der letzten sitzung darüber
diskutiert ich machte auch in den kurven
rechts rein ob man überhaupt von
autonomie sprechen kann es gibt
verschiedene vorstellungen von autonomie
man kann die auffassung vertreten dass
künstlich intelligente systeme schwach
autonom sind an das ist eine auffassung
ich spreche lieber davon dass die
hypothetisch autonom sind dass sie also
sich eigentlich gar kein wirkliches
gesetz geben das ist ja autonomie das
ist das gesetz sind dass sie das gesetz
immer von außen bekommen aber dann wenn
sie das gesetz von außen bekommen die
vorschrift des ziel das ist dieses
hypothetische dass sie dann unter diesen
bedingungen gewissen spielraum haben der
eben mit der funktionsweise von
neuronalen letzten zusammenhängt dass
diese netze lernen unter neuen
situationen das war der unterschied auch
zwischen symbolischer ki und
kollektivistische
kanalnetze
ja das ist so dieses thema und das
wollen wir auch jetzt abschließen in der
heutigen sitzung weil wir uns schon mit
33 mal damit befasst haben werden jetzt
haben ein paar leitfragen was versteht
man ein guter ein roboter
wie können wir die autonomie von
robotern weiter analysieren inwiefern
sie autonom und dann und das die
entscheidende frage für unsere seminar
sitzungen und die seminar sitzung
speziell welche ethik oder welcher ethik
typ ist für roboter eigentlich
angemessen um sie ethisch angemessen zu
verstehen es gibt es ja einige bücher
die ich empfehlen kann es gibt dieses
buch fx die ethik der digitalen zeit
davon habe ich ihn auch schon den ein
oder anderen text zugänglich gemacht da
sind auch sehr kurze texte drin
dann kann ich ihn empfehlen da lesen
heute auch einen text rau sowie
diskutieren zumindest über diese autonom
waffensysteme und dann gibt es ein neues
buch über roboter und kritik dass auch
auf die grundlagen dieser technik tätig
eingeht das ist denke ich auch sehr
sinnvoll wenn man sich etwas mit den
grundlagen befassen möchte wir gehen
heute ein bisschen auf diese grundlagen
auch einem rahmen der zeit die wir haben
jetzt gibt es wie gesagt verschiedenen
ethische typen oder paradigmen die sich
anbieten um diese phänomene der
künstlichen intelligenz aber speziell
der roboter der autonomen roboter zu
behandeln und auch zu bewerten also
ethische thesen theorien wurden ja auch
immer etwas darüber herausfinden was wir
tun soll oder eben vielleicht auch
besser nicht tun sollten aus einem
moralischen standpunkt aus einem
normativen gesichtspunkt heraus wir
machen ja nicht nur technik philosophie
seine technik frage ist überhaupt ob der
die bezeichnung technik tätig dafür noch
angemessen ist dass man das als technik
versteht technik hat man so diesen
instrumentellen charakter und diese
instrumentelle charakter der
verschwindet immer mehr wer sich
künstliche intelligenz immer mehr in
unsere alltäglichen praktiken
einbeziehen lässt da erscheint uns
künstliche intelligenz gar nicht mehr
als etwas was wir als instrument nutzen
sind es ist so nahtlos drin dass wir uns
gar nicht mehr als solche wahrnehmen
jetzt haben wir hier das erste paradigma
nämlich die ideologie das haben sie
sicherlich alles schon mal gehört das
geht zurück auf immer anerkannt
da mache ich dann auch oben rechts sind
videolink rhein zu seiner theorie das
moralisch guten einem anderen seminar
als internet.de und theologie und
theologische ethik da geht es darum als
immanuel kant geben der beispielhafte
philosoph dafür dass der moralische wird
einmal handlung sich an der motivation
also der
individuellen subjektiven motivation
bemisst die des jeweiligen der erde die
handelt und der frage wie fern die würde
einer person dadurch gewahrt bleibt sie
kennen alle die formulierung des
kategorischen imperativs
die auch gesagt dass man
die andere person nie nur als mittel zum
zweck sind als selbstzweck als absoluten
zweck behandeln sollten und darin ist
gerade auch die würde der anderen person
ausgedrückt
sequenzen eine handlung sind nach der
auffassung der diätologie eher
nebensächlich immanuel kant beschreibt
es so oder so sagt ein guter wille als
eine gute motivation die ist allein gut
zu nennen die konsequenzen die haben wir
irgendwie auch nicht so ganz in der hand
unserer handlung wir haben selbst die
handlung nicht ganz in der hand weil
wenn wir den willen stand so motiviert
hätten dass er handlungs wirksam werden
könnte könnten ja immer noch äußere
umstände eintreten auf die uns daran
hindern
dass wir zu handeln kommen und nach kant
ist nur dasjenige ethisch zu bewerten
was wir wirklich absolut im griff haben
und da sagt eben es liegt nicht so sehr
in unseren willen wie unser wille selbst
das ist wiederum ein zitat von
augustinus dann mache ich oben rechts
und links zum anderen seminar der eben
diese auffassung vertreten hatte nur
unser wille ist eigentlich der grund des
guten oder bösen ja das ist eben ein
paradigma das ist ein sehr häufiges
paradigma das muss man sich fragen kann
man mit diesem paradigma solche
phänomene wie kampfroboter und ihre
handlungen sage ich jetzt mal ihre
aktion angemessen verstehen ein zweites
paradigma das ist ja die ontologie
gerade entgegen gesetzt das ist der
konsequenz ii allis muss wie der name
schon sagt da geht es um die
konsequenzen also der moralische werte
einer handlung gemäss sich nicht an dem
was ihr zugrunde liegt also nicht an der
motivation
das ist genau die entgegengesetzte
perspektive es geht um die folgen dieser
handlung und die können eben
quantifiziert werden die kann
objektiviert werden wie viel nutzen wird
durch die handlung erzählt die handlung
aber würde 50 nutzens punkte er bringt
die handlung b70 nutzens punkte also
wählen wir die handlung b und zeichnen
sie aus hier stellt sich natürlich immer
die frage wie kann man genau die folgen
ja bemessen nach welchen kriterien
bemessen wir die folgen was es überhaupt
das größte glück dann ist die frage in
welchem zeitraum gemessen wir die
größten folgen es kann ja sein dass eine
handlung in kurzer zeit sehr viel
positive wirkungen hat auf lange frist
vielleicht sogar negative und eine
andere zunächst war gar keine positiven
und auf lange frist hin immer mehr als
es ganz schwierig das zu objektivieren
das ist eines dieser probleme des
kontinents ii allis muss auf der anderen
seite hat er natürlich auf seiner seite
dass man hier sehr schön sehen kann was
gut ist es geht um die nutzen es geht
also die konkretion und daran mangelt es
da dieser technologie so ein bisschen ja
dass man hier den nutzen nicht so großes
zelt und stellte es geht einfach um die
gesinnung die moralische gesinnung die
hinter einer handlung steht und auch die
man häufig eben gerade nicht erkennen
kann wir können eben eine handlung sehr
schlecht ansehen von einer anderen
person die hier gesinnung dahinter war
da das ist auch ein objektivität problem
das hat der konsequenz müssen uns nicht
dafür hatte eben die anderen genannten
probleme dann gibt es noch
klassischerweise zum schluss noch die
sogenannte two genetik das bedeutet der
moralische wert einer handlung vermisst
sich daran ob sie einer tugend
entsprungen ist und was ist jetzt eine
tugend da geht man meistens zurück auf
aristoteles dann mache ich auch oben
rechts und links zu dieser sitzung wo es
um seine jugend ethik ging eine tugend
ist eine charaktereigenschaft oder eine
haltung einer person und diese haltung
ist so dass sie eine ausgewogene
mittelposition eine ausgewogene mitte
darstellt zwischen moralisch
problematische extremen ein beispiel ist
etwa dass man sagt es gibt die
tapferkeit die tapferkeit oder die
besonnenheit und die liegt eben zwischen
der tollkühnheit also dem zu großem
wagemut und der feigheit die
besonnenheit die tapferkeit die liegt
irgendwo in der mitte es ist immer etwas
reflektiert das als die mitte hattest
immer mit reflexion zu tun da wird
ausgerichtet da wird austariert die
gesunde mittlere beste
haltung angesichts einer möglichen
fragestellung wie wir uns zum beispiel
jetzt in einer schwierigen situation
verhalten sollen da sagt eben
aristoteles besonnen und besonnen ist
eben immer eine mitte die richtige
mittel die aber immer für jedes objekt
anders zu ermitteln ist es gibt hier
nicht die mitte dass man hier einfach
eine strecke nimmt und dann die
arithmetische mittel nimmt sondern dass
immer die mitte für uns jede person die
verschiedene anlagen und charakter
eigenschaften mitbringt das ist so ein
dritter einsatz ja jetzt kann man sich
fragen auf welche tugenden lässt jetzt
bitteschön diese einsatz der
waffentechnik schließen
sie eine gesunde mittel gewählt das wäre
der politische ansatz der konsequenz ii
allis tisch ansatz wäre
ja wie konsequenzen bringt eine solche
solche einsatz mit sich dieser neuen
techniken und die erste frage wäre dann
hier wird die würde der person wirklich
gewahrt wenn wir diese techniken
einsetzen ja jetzt kann man hier neues
thema noch bringen nämlich das thema
ethik und fiktion das wird in meinen
augen viel zu selten behandelt und das
besagt dass ethische theorien nicht nur
auf die vergangenheit um die gegenwart
reflektieren sollten sondern eben auch
auf eine mögliche zukunft die zukunft
hat das problem an sich dass sie immer
nur eben möglich ist wir wissen nie
genau was kommt wir können versuchen sie
zu antizipieren aber das hammer eben
nicht im griff das heißt eine etikette
ist nicht nur mit der notwendigkeit mit
dem was gewesen ist was notwendig
gewesen ist und der wirklichkeit dem was
jetzt der fall ist zu tun sondern auch
mit der möglichkeit das ist klappt es
ganz wichtig dass man in der regel immer
sich auch mögliche szenarien mal
vorstellen mal durchspielt und
infektionen als in erzählung geschichten
auch besonders und science fiction
szenarien da zeigen sich eben vielleicht
neue ethische dimensionen oder probleme
die früher oder später noch real werden
können das heißt es ist in der durchaus
für science fiction szenarien wenn es um
eine ethik geht es könnte man eine ethik
der zukunft in taufen jetzt gibt es hier
einen pionier auf diesem feld haben sie
vielleicht schon gehört isaac asimov ein
amerikanisch russischer jahr
naturwissenschaftler forscher aber auch
ein schriftsteller hat gelebt von 19.20
bis 9 92 und dieser schriftsteller hat
eben ein buch verfasst das ist das buch
ich der roboter ist aus den 50ern und
das gibt es auch auf deutsch
der übersetzung das ist das original
layout cover von diesem buch wie wir
sehen hier schon eine stilisierte figur
so wie man sich eben ein roboter
vorstellt das interessante ist jetzt
dass hier ich der roboter steht also der
roboter verfügt offensichtlich zumindest
nach dieser erzählung über subjektivität
über qualia er kann auf sich selbst
bezog mehr hat selbstbewusstsein das ist
natürlich eine ganz spannende frage bei
mit selbstbewusstsein häufig eben auch
autonomie in verbindung gebracht wird
das ist zumindest jetzt hier ein science
fiction szenario hier noch ein bild von
dieser schriftsteller und er hat ganz
viele bücher geschrieben die immer in
diesem umkreis angesiedelt sind häufig
auch bücher für ein breites lesepublikum
also nicht für einen strengen
wissenschaftliches publikum und jetzt
hatte hier roboter gesetze formuliert in
einem seiner bücher und da ist die
lauten folgendermaßen also hat drei
gesetzte hat verschiedene gesetzt immer
wieder formuliert das sind diese drei
zentralen erstens ein roboter darf kein
menschliches wesen wissentlich
verletzten wurde durch und eklig kyte
wissentlich zu lassen aus einem
menschlichen wesen schaden zugefügt wird
ja also es geht darum wenn es um schaden
geht dann muss der roboter aufpassen
also er ist letztendlich grundsätzlich
von seinem interesse
demjenigen der menschen untergeordnet
haben als er muss in jeder weise sei es
durch tun oder unterlassen
durch nicht unterlassen einer handlung
muss er menschlichen schaden vermeiden
das ist also schon mal ein ziemlich
gute die touristisch konsequenz ii allis
tische ansatz hatte eben nach dem nutzen
geht es gedauert dass diese roboter ein
jahr einen möglichst großen nutzen
bringt und natürlich hier immer noch
wesentlich
darstellt natürlich die frage kann ein
roboter das wissen was durch ihnen
passiert was durch ihn auch unterlassen
wird
ja kann er das war wissen man könnte
sagen gut verstehen wir wissen einfach
mal anders wissen im sinne von
errechnen ja diese roboter hat so große
rechenkapazitäten
dass er oder sie
eben
prognostizieren kann dass unter den
gegebenen bedingungen mit einer großen
wahrscheinlichkeit schaden eintreten
würde und dann muss er sie ist eben
dementsprechend handeln die frage stellt
sich auch ob er wirklich verhandlungs
begriff angemessen ist dann muss eben
eine aktion folgen zweites gesetz ein
roboter muss den ihm von einem menschen
gegebenen befehlen
es sei denn ein solcher befehl würde mit
regel 1 kollidieren also hier wieder
sieht man die unterordnung des roboters
unter die interessen des menschen auch
befehle er ist praktisch nicht wirklich
autonom weil er eben nicht sich selbst
gesetzte gehen kann das hatten wir auch
schon diskutiert das wäre ein problem
bin roboter wirklich autonomen werden
dann dürften wir ihnen eigentlich gar
keine vorschriften machen das wäre ja
ein eingriff ihre autonomie deswegen
muss diese autonome eine hypothetische
autonomie sein sie muss immer unter der
bedingung der menschlichen autonomie
stillen stehen und der roboter darf auch
nicht einen befehl folgen der eben damit
kollidiert mit gesetz 1 dass dadurch
eben einem anderen menschen schaden
zugefügt würde ja das ist jetzt
natürlich die frage wie sieht's aus mit
kriegs verboten demnach dürfte es
eigentlich gar keine kriegsreporter
geben weil da wäre ja gerade der fall 2
eingetreten dass menschen dem roboter
befehlen anderen menschen schaden
zuzufügen dann müsste er sich eigentlich
viren dagegen ja
geht das überhaupt dass ein roboter so
programmiert ist dass es sich gar nicht
für solche zwecke
instrumentalisieren lässt das wäre
natürlich auch eine spannende frage nach
seiner autonomie es wird dann
gewissermaßen eine negative autonomie
wäre ein würde programm dass wir diesen
roboter ein programmieren müssten das
tier 1 würde detektor hätte oder genauer
gesagt ein würde verletzungs detektor
dass er immer daneben ja sich nicht mehr
rühren würde dass er sich seine
aktivität einstellen würde wenn er
dieses würde
verletzungsmuster erkennen würde also
hier wird jetzt ein anderer mensch
schaden zugefügt wird stelle ich meine
aktivitäten ein so ein modul oder so ein
system müsste diesen roboter
einprogrammiert sein und zwar essentiell
seine existenz identität müsste mit
diesen programmen stehen und fallen
drittens ein roboter muss seine existenz
beschützen so lange dieser schutz nicht
mit regel eins oder zwei kollidiert das
finde ich jetzt auch ganz spannend ich
liege jetzt jetzt letztendlich und
gewissermaßen personale identität des
roboters er hat eine identität die
auch schützenswert ist aber eben immer
nur hypothetisch nämlich unter der
bedingung dass eben dadurch nicht
anderen schaden zugefügt wird ja also er
ist in jeder hinsicht hinsichtlich
seiner aktivitäten seiner regel und
sogar hinsichtlich seiner existenz seine
identitäts bedingung den menschlichen
interessen untergeordnet finde ich sehr
spannend finde ich sehr
nachdenkenswert hier muss man sich
sicherlich fragen ja was ist den schaden
ist schade nur äußerliche schaden
verletzungen wie ist das definiert das
ist zwar auch hier existenz schützen
also das würde zum beispiel bedeuten
wenn jetzt ein tier
1 nicht menschliches tier
den roboter angreifen würde dass ein
hund
weil er denken würde das ist irgendwie
ein monster dann dürfte der roboter sich
verteidigen er dürfte vielleicht sogar
das tier angreifen um sich in
roboterhafte notwehr zu schützen das ist
die frage also ist dann ein roboter von
seiner würde form von seinem
schutzbedürftigkeit dem eines der eines
tieres der schutzwürdigkeit über
zuordnen das würde jetzt daraus folgen
ja weil er nur der mensch das
menschliche tier den roboter
übergeordnet ist finde ich sehr spannend
zu diskutieren sie können da mal schauen
meine freunde die roboter aus diesem
beruf genommen und auf wikipedia findet
sich ja auch noch mehr ins dazu jetzt
kann man mal ganz konkret auf die
letalen autonomen die live oktober mit
ökonomischen systems die sogenannten los
zu sprechen letale automobil
waffensysteme was es damit auf sich hat
hier haben wir aus diesen ersten
genannten buch ein aufsatz ein interview
eigentlich jetzt zur diskussion war es
ursprünglich auf englisch erschienen
nämlich von jean baptist church in will
mehr der einen englischen aufsatz
geschrieben hat herr termin fx sowie
band killer roboter aus dem jahr
2015 in asics ein international afrique
erschienen kann man im internet sicher
nachlesen und hier sieht man jetzt ein
solches ja
waffensystem man zieht es hat ja als ein
kettenfahrzeug
es hat hier oben eine
montur das ist wahrscheinlich die waffe
sieht man verschiedene
antennen das sind wahrscheinlich
sensoren und es gibt auch noch andere
solche autonom waffensysteme
halbautonomen wie auch immer sie haben
häufig auch
anthropomorphe gestalt auch manchmal
sehen sie aus wie st und dann haben sie
vier beine man sieht hier es geht hier
immer um ja ähnlichkeiten man neigt dazu
solche systeme immer mehr auch
menschlicher oder tierischer gestalt
nachzubilden hier unten ist es auf
diesem bild noch nicht so klar der fall
das ist so ein kleiner mobiler panzer
kann man sagen zum kettenfahrzeug je
mehr aber dieses gefährt wieder gestalt
annimmt von füßen verarmen wenn es ihm
nachgebildet wird lebendigen wesen ja
umso mehr wird das von nanometern also
menschenähnlich die frage ist ob aus
dieser ähnlichkeit irgendwas ethisch
folgt das ist ja erstmal nur eine
äußerlichkeit
jedenfalls denkt ist es so eine
entwicklung abgezeichnet und jetzt
wollen wir hier diskutieren was der
unterschied zwischen rms und laos sind
rms sind den robot heißt military air
systems die sind dem menschen
immer untergeordnet insofern alster
immer menschen in entscheidungsprozesse
involviert sind und zwar am besten
unmittelbar also das wäre etwa diese
drohne diese unbemannte drohne gekriegt
die von einer zentrale gesteuert werden
haben die steuernde person ein
bildschirm hat und dann eben befehle
weiterleitet durch einen fernseher ist
alles klassische fernstudiums
beispiel das sind eben nur
importierte militärische systeme und das
können auch weitere komplexe roboter
sein die einfach mittelbar befehle
empfangen und dann ausführen die stehe
jetzt nicht so sehr im zentrum sondern
eher diesel aus die lieferung des
waffensystems da sind jetzt eben keine
menschen mehr
unmittelbar zumindest in den
entscheidungsprozess
involviert das heißt hier agieren diese
systeme gewissermaßen unter den
bedingungen dass sie ein bestimmtes
führen sollen autonom weil ihnen die
konkrete durchführung dieses befehls
überlassen klagt ja und hier stellen sie
jetzt eben die ethischen probleme wenn
zum beispiel dann die wahl ist die
entscheidung ist diese menschen zu töten
oder diesel handelt es sich um
zivilisten oder um gegnerische einheiten
und jetzt stellt sich die frage ist es
inhärent falsch wenn diese los wenn
diese
automatischen waffensystemen diese
tödlichen wenn die menschen töten sei es
jetzt zivilisten sowieso oder eben auch
gegnerische einheiten weil diese
gegnerischen einheiten dadurch
instrumentalisiert und zu bloßen
objekten degradiert werden das ist eine
der fragen die in diesen genannten
aufsetzt diskutiert werden sie müssen
sich vorstellen ein soldat einer
gegnerischen partei wird durch ein so
automatisches
waffensystem getötet weil dieses system
ausgerechnet hat und das eben er jetzt
der beste feind ist und der andere feind
der vielleicht fünf kilometer weg ist
besser erstmal nicht getötet wird weil
der vielleicht nicht so gut zu treffen
ist also macht es jetzt ein unterschied
ob ein gegnerischer soldat durch ein rms
system roboters militärisches dem alter
durch einen direkten unmittelbaren
befehl einer anderen person mittels eben
dieses gerätes getötet oder durch ein
solches autonomes waffensystem jetzt
könnte man sagen ja es macht einen
unterschied das letzte position der
theologie weil hier die würde dieses
menschen verletzt wird weil er nicht von
einem menschlichen wesen angegriffen
wurde weil er letztendlich ja von einem
roboter getötet wurde am ende könnte man
aber sagen konsequenz realistisch macht
doch keinen unterschied ob jetzt die
ausführende instanz ein mensch war oder
ein autonomes waffensystem ist doch ein
hacker
kann man sich fragen also ändert sich
der moralischen status einer handlung
wenn menschen mit ms oder los getötet
werden im krieg natürlich natürlich umso
schwieriger die frage wenn es sich eben
nicht um krieg situation andere da
macht es einen unterschied
das ist eine frage die es demnächst noch
diskutieren wollen ich will damit noch
eine sache ins spiel bringen nämlich
diese los diese im völkerrecht schon ein
bisschen angedacht sind sie kennen alle
die genfer
konventionen es gibt jetzt
in die ahl um 177 wurde da ein
zusatzprotokoll
aufgenommen nämlich über den schutz der
opfer internationaler bewaffneter
konflikte und das lautet jetzt
folgendermaßen
jede vertragspartei also die mitglieder
eben die sich diesen konventionen
angeschlossen haben diese vertragspartei
ist verpflichtet in artikel 36 der die
neuen waffen betrifft das sind zum
beispiel diesel aus ist pflicht bei der
prüfung entwicklung beschaffung oder
einführung neuer waffen oder neuer
mittel oder methoden der kriegsführung
festzustellen ob ihre verbindung stets
unter bestimmten umständen durch dieses
protokoll oder durch eine andere auf
tirol vertragspartei anwender regelt das
zunächst verboten wäre das ist natürlich
jetzt noch sehr vage formuliert
was ist denn jetzt eine methode der
kriegsführung was ist denn eine
verbindung was sie denn die bestimmte
umstände ja also hier wird zumindest
jetzt ein zusatzartikel aufgenommen der
x diese möglichkeit von solchen ja
system erhöht und zumindest auch
problematisiert und dafür 10 mobilisiert
die zukunft wird uns leider muss man
sagen da noch ganz andere entwicklung
dringend mit dem fortschreiten von
künstlicher intelligenz jetzt verhandelt
mit der künstlichen neuronalen netze
wird es neue muster erkennungs form
geben sodass eben auch kriegsführung als
ein komplexes muster verstanden werden
kann nicht nur wie ein schadprogramm wo
es um züge geht sonst wohl so komplexe
erkenntnisse geht von
geländebeschaffenheit vom
truppenbewegungen von truppenstärke von
zivilisten unterscheidung und eben
kriegsführenden parteien wo objekte und
lebendige wesen identifiziert werden das
ist denke ich nur eine frage der zeit
bis sich hier auch neue waffensysteme im
sinne der neuen medien entwickeln und
uns sicherlich für ganz schwierige
moralische entscheidungen stellen
dasselbe gilt natürlich auch für polizei
systeme in der überwachung und auch in
dem schutz der bevölkerung
innerstaatlich nicht nur außer staatlich
auch hier stellt sich die frage ob diese
neuen systeme
irgendwann so ausgereift sind werden
dass man ihn immer mehr entscheidungen
überlässt weil sie vielleicht aufs ganze
gesehen zuverlässiger funktionieren eine
höhere trefferquote sage jetzt mal haben
alte menschliche personen haben die
dahinter stehen ja dann stellen sich
eben die fragen wird dadurch nicht die
würde einer anderen person verletzt wenn
wir sie letztendlich unter die gewalt
und die entscheidung so halt eines
künstlichen systems stellen
darüber werden jetzt gleich diskutieren
nach einer kurzen ausblick auf die
nächste sitzung es geht da dann nicht
mehr direkt zumindest und künstliche
intelligenz auch wenn künstliche
intelligenz eigentlich in jeder der
sitzung die wir noch haben mit schwingen
wird ist ganz konkret um das thema trans
humanismus trans humanismus bedeutet
eine sehr technik optimistische
auffassung wonach der mensch sich durch
die neuen medien durch die neuen
technologien
eben auch verbessert und sich selbst
verändert als mann liegt hier eine art
von technologischer evolutionstheorie
zugrunde wonach der mensch immer mehr
mit seiner technologie verschmilzt also
er selbst wird immer mehr technologische
und die technik wird immer mehr
menschlicher als nähert sich also von
beiden seiten gewissermaßen alles
konvergiert und am ende steht eben
solche szenarien wie man die these dass
wir unseren geist im sinne der software
aktualisieren können vielleicht auch
duplizieren können dass wir vielleicht
unsterblich werden länger leben das sind
alles utopische szenarien das
optimistische szenario es in szenarien
die sich durchaus um eine tradition der
aufklärung bringen lassen hier ist das
stichwort singularität die annahme dass
zu einem bestimmten nicht mehr allzu
fern zeitpunkt die technik so weit
entwickelt ist dass sie
selbstbewusstsein hervorbringt das ganz
neue dinge möglich sind die uns auch von
unserer endlichen beschränkung durch
unser körper lösen und solche thesen
werden wir diskutieren natürlich immer
unter ethischen gesichtspunkten uns
fragen ob sie ethische oder zeugen sind
und welche probleme ethisch damit einher
geht ja das wird eine spannende sitzung
jetzt bedanke mich für die
aufmerksamkeit und wünschen noch einen
schönen tag